[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a revisiting of a phone that probably
got some of the biggest hype of 2013 and
judging from the comments section of my
ces bag tour video and many other people
on twitter etc people want to know how
this phone has been holding up and it's
been about four months since the full
review so the natural place to start
would be the hardware because when it
first came out this galaxy note 3 design
was one of the most talked about in
samsung's lineup specifically the
material choices so the size of the
phone were the first in any samsung
phone to appear sort of metal like the
galaxy s4 but it's a soft material and
it's held up pretty well but really it's
the back of the phone here that's gotten
a lot of attention it's the fake
leatherette stitching and soft touch
feel now i actually like this feel on my
black galaxy note 3. i've actually
switched to the black one since the
review it's a little bit less soft on
the white note 3 to avoid staining and i
think that was a smart move from samsung
and as soft as it is there's really only
one small blemish on the back of my
phone and it's only noticeable from
certain angles when it catches the light
well that would have been a full-on
scratch on a plastic phone like the
galaxy s4 but then again it probably
never would have been seen on a metal
phone like the htc one so this this soft
touch design and the stitching is
somewhere in the middle and i kind of
dig it i like holding it and the
stitching is also now made its way
through all of samsung's lineup
including the galaxy gear smart watch
and their new tablets and even some of
their packaging so i wouldn't be
surprised at all to see the galaxy s5
rock this same material but that's
another video either way i take really
good care of all my electronics and i
don't really actually use any cases or
screen protectors on any of my phones
which some people think is crazy
but this galaxy note 3 has been
perfectly fine to withstand that test
anyway what i was hoping would be better
with this phone is the software so in my
original review i talked more about this
in depth and of course i'll leave the
link to the full review right below that
like button if you want to check it out
again relive that but essentially since
i've gotten it i've done everything i
can short of rooting it to make it a
sort of a google edition galaxy note 3.
i grabbed the google experience launcher
from kitkat a bunch of the aosp google
themed apps the keyboard and i basically
mirrored it to my nexus 5 as much as
possible to make it more pleasant for me
to use
and of course with its top notch specs
none of that really impacted the
performance but here's the thing no
matter how hard you try you can't shake
touchwiz it pops up wherever you go in
this phone in the settings in the
notification panel in the visual styles
and the fonts uh it's everywhere and at
this point i actually don't really like
touchwiz that much i much prefer stock
android from something like the nexus 5
and not only that but you got to
remember that since this phone has come
out a new version of android has
released it's android 4.4 kitkat and
this phone doesn't have it yet it's
still running android 4.3 jelly bean now
not that that's old or anything but just
today samsung announced uh they released
the kernel source for android 4.4 on the
note 3. so that's definitely on its way
soon but even when that drops it'll
still only change so much and ultimately
it'll still be touchwiz and touchwiz has
so many features and so many alterations
that it actually impacts speed in a
couple of ways it impacts the speed of
the operation of this phone it's such a
heavy skin that the phone actually needs
all three gigs of ram that it has and it
impacts the speed of updates so you know
how we keep seeing those motorola phones
like the moto x and the moto g get super
fast updates to kitkat it's because they
run a version of android that is very
very close to stock and that will never
happen with the galaxy note 3 because of
touchwiz so if you're not into rooting
you'll have to settle for finding
equivalents of stock android features in
the play store like i did and i managed
to find a lot but really not everything
is a perfect equivalent i look through
all the stock themed camera apps for
example in the play store and they all
seem to work alright they can take quick
photos none of them are particularly bad
but none of them can record 4k video
like the touchwiz camera can on the note
3 and they all seem to crash when
attempting to take a photo sphere or a
panorama or do anything too fancy so
this is the reason why i have two of a
lot of apps on my note 3. one aosp
themed app and one touchwiz one to back
it up that i just have to keep around
and that camera i want is actually kind
of a big deal i really wish i could tap
into 4k video more often with the stock
camera interface because the footage
looks phenomenal if you don't believe me
check out some recent super scientific
videos shot on his galaxy note 3. they
are crispy i'll leave some links below
but other than that this phone is just
as great as you'd expect after a few
months of launch and it's been
surprisingly successful for samsung you
know we the whole galaxy note line
started as basically an experiment and
this third version has sold way more
than 10 million for them so they are
really serious about it now it's no
longer an experiment
other minor things i wish the camera had
optical image stabilization to make the
video even better
i wish it had wireless charging built in
like the nexus 5 instead of having to
spend extra money on a case that adds it
and i wish the design of the ui was just
better than what samsung has here with
touchwiz so really at the end of the day
when you're looking at a phone like the
note 3 you look at the software if you
like the software that that whole
touchwiz experience and you like the
hardware this is still a great phone and
it's one that i have no doubts will be
super super duper future proof because
of all the great specs the massive
amount of ram the great display it's
just all around a great phone and we all
know that i'm not a person that uses a
stylus that much so i'm actually really
into this phone still because i can
pretty much guarantee you that when this
phone gets a cyanogen mod build a stable
build of the rom that brings the aosp
experience to this phone it'll be
getting a lot more use from me than it
already has so there you go guys thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
[Music]
you